he's Kevin mala you can watch Kevin and
Chris Rose co-host intentional talk at
5:00 p.m. from Fenway and then though
also be a Dodger Stadium throughout the
World Series where are you right now
Kevin I'm gonna tell you right now damn
ask you one question cuz you know how I
usually ask you a question have we
started to show off yeah when's the last
time you had a man sleepover like like
you said you know what dance sleepover
let's have a guy sleepover it's usually
the kids once the last time you've had a
sleepover then I actually planned it no
no no you being planning you just end up
you're out you had a few cocktails and
your buddy says hey why don't you sleep
over my house and you know what you look
him in the eyes you go
yep I'm in let's go what's the last time
that happened are you with Chris Rose
right now and a sleepover and you are
you in your no no he shaped life but
like an avocado I'm not with Chris Rose
right now I haven't seen him yet we flew
in different times let me just tell you
right now okay give me a hint I am a
hint okay I'll give you a hint give you
a hint he had a lot of home runs for us
in 2003 four and five you're a big
Papi's house all right Danny that's
exactly right so big Papi's house Big
Papi has a restaurant you know big
Papi's won a few last rock stars we've
had in baseball yeah so I had a
sleepover with Heidi DeRosa that's mark
DeRosa's wife with Mark DeRosa okay all
right okay myself and Big Papi we end up
back at his house he said well come back
to our house let's have a sleepover so
guess what
we had a don't sleep over it was great
we woke up this morning I don't know
where I'm at had no cell service I'm
excited I'm talking to you on his
landline what kind of what kind of crib
does Big Papi have amazing the nice
backyard let me walk away real quick
simple green grass bode he's got a
soccer goal so I'd know papi was into
soccer we have a play scape we have a
pool that's covered here in Boston we
have a basketball hoop next to the pool
but that's absolutely gorgeous out right
now what's for breakfast you know what
he stays and takes a breakfast at some
place down the road but it's already
9:40 so make sure I hopefully breakfast
is not noon because I want to miss
intentional talk did papi want to have
you stay over or did you just sort of
say I'm staying over it's a valid
he invited us okay no I love Heidi to
Rosa because she looked at us like yeah
I'm in there's not a stick of makeup
there's not a stick you know how girls
gotta have your bags she's all in so
that's why mark she's a gamer and she's
here and yeah we we were all on the same
clothes we had last night man you got
makeup on makeup is on from the last
yesterday show I went straight to
airport airport - boss JetBlue my TV
didn't work almost cried from my night
football landed Papi's restaurant BAM
here we are same makeup bombing
yesterday
all right let's dive into this here game
one coming up best player on each team
best player on the Red Sox in the World
Series will be I pick Jackie Bradley jr.
for my sneaky play last series this
series best player will be a lot of the
lefthand stars for the dodgers so I'm
gonna go with the Red Sox and Lukie bets
will go off okay the best player on the
Dodgers in this world series will be
Justin Turner okay he is the best player
on the daughters in this world series
he's fun he's the guy if you're the
Dodgers I want him up with the game on
the line I know Puig was great in the
last series and Bellinger but Turner's
the guy with game on the line who's the
game game on the line for the Red Sox
the guy you won up if you're Korra what
right-handed hitter
I mean right-handed pitcher on the mound
since we're ended all the sabermetrics
day and age and you only get one a bad
in the third inning and then you can
take out of the game and we got right he
come in so yeah we'll get that in there
a day
I'll go Ben intend II look and intend
these up eighth inning two hours
right-hander he's the guy better
starting pitching that's a good question
I'm gonna go with the Boston Red Sox
alright
Benson's closer do you want who do you
want on the mound Dan Patrick Kenley
Jansen Craig Kimbrel
well if Kim Burrell is not tipping his
pitches then I'm I'm gonna go Kimbrel
and okay how does this work in the
baseball community Eric Gagne who
pitched for the Dodgers
seems that Kimbrough is tipping his
pitches then reaches out to his buddy
Cora and says hey your your
tipping his pitches how do you think
this is going over with the Dodgers yeah
that's an interesting dynamic I think
every single pitcher out there at some
point tips of pitches I think owls
course is one of the greatest pitch
tipper finder hires let's use that out
in the history of baseball I play with
Alice Cora the good thing is I showered
with both these managers so they're both
good good young men think about that
Danny I know I'm trying not yeah I'm
trying not about it
shower with both of them you can't say
that about sleepover last night and a
shower with both managers in the World
Series a new shower and scene with Big
Papi - and Big Papi knife showered many
times yes so you know I think there's a
lot of things when you think of Kevin
Marty like man he showers in the 2018
World Series managers he's done it all
he's done it all alright we've never
showered together though you and I not
yet but you know I we got time hopefully
I got a long live keV
have you showered with Chris Rose
I've never showered with Chris Rose I've
seen him with his shirt off he had a
sleepover at my house but we planned
that as a family sleepover last week he
came out he doesn't like snakes
I threw a fake snake out sounds like a
boy seen him with a shirt off and that's
a rarity you never see Rosie with his
shirt off god bless is there a reason
you know he's not as bad as he gives out
to be you know he's done a great job of
watching his weight he grabs my french
fries he orders the broccoli the salmon
broccoli I ordered a burger and fries he
always reaches over my plate first
before I even had a french fry so he
plays the good health role but no
there's no reason this is you know much
yeah that's the Power Move um did you
buy into the Chris Sale bellybutton ring
thing no it was the greatest game ever
now stay with me
he's got arm shoulder back delivery
problems whatever it is is velocity is
down two and a half miles an hour but
you know why guys I'm sorry I have an
infected bellybutton ring and for two
days I'd put Neosporin on it it's a
great skit media-wise they go off and
write this story all the pressures off
the little sling and Lefty love it no
it's not off there's no pressure off of
him because of a bellybutton ring they
stopped all the reports about his arm
back sore he missed he had to go to
hospital so all we're talking about is
his battling or neosporin around
navel area is the best left-hander on
the mound tonight will be Clayton
Kershaw and crew soon Chris Sale
lot of designers let me tell you it's
another world Northeast baseball allowed
and played up here it's gonna be fun for
them they're gonna walk out see the
Green Monster and who and ha next thing
you know sale could have be flinging
about eight strikeouts tonight I don't
know how long they go cuz they be you
could stay in ovations if you go four
innings that's the good thing about
baseball you don't have to go for these
days can you walk in we're talking to
Kevin Millar Major League Baseball
Network analyst he's staying at big
Papi's he had a would you walk in and
tell me what's in big Papi's
refrigerator yeah hold on let me walk in
right here mmm
yes Louis Lewis drove us out here so
Louis been with Big Papi
Bente anos which is about 20 years okay
he's got eggs
we have fat-free milk we have heavy
cream we have Rose rose but sugar
deployer Rose Blanco which would be
grilled chicken and then I went to the
store last night and bought us this is
no joke on the way home I bought us
hostesses last time you've had mini
frosted doughnuts okay that's a that's a
sneaky buy late at night but then you're
looking at it in the morning and then I
think you think differently right play
nice though there okay
that's it you're not cowboying up though
there's no more shots before the game
you don't do that anymore that was last
night
with shots of Jack dance last night one
shot just a toast to the nation wait was
that what you guys did prior to the
games in the World Series you didn't oh
I didn't know if I knew that you did you
know shots I didn't know what you were
doing shots of Jack Daniels in Yankee
Stadium Crown Royal in st. Louis they
didn't have Jack Daniels so we had to
keep it going we're eight know after
having a symbolic toast
remember our word you and I that's our
secret yeah no one listened to show
anyways right oh they do not your night
dogyum just yeah just you and I no one's
listening
we'll have fun tidy hey Allison like you
first sleepover in Austin Texas soon
okay bye but if I come then my dance
come to 100% dad okay good and bring
your golf clubs I sleep in the nude
shower in the morning thank you Kevin
I've voiced with CJ that's Kevin Milan
man he's a party in a box for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]